well we're all familiar with the first
internet the communication internet
we've been on it for 24 25 years most of
us we use the internet all the time to
communicate and send information the
energy internet is very very new it's
now actually being built out in places
like Germany in Denmark and across
Europe so it's no longer academic here's
how it works we are moving toward
renewable energy across Europe we have
millions and millions now of buildings
homes offices factories retail stores
that have been transformed into micro
power plants and they are producing
their own green electricity on-site
solar panels on the roof vertical wind
on the property
geothermal pumps for energy underneath
the ground bio converters to convert
garbage to biomass energy in the
kitchens etc in Germany alone
we've retrofitted 1 million buildings
made them efficient put in the
insulation and put these new renewable
technologies on the building a million
buildings are producing their own green
electricity and there's a feed-in tariff
that gives them premium for sending
their electricity back to the grid they
get more than the market price so now
we're setting up storage and an energy
internet you have to store these
energies the Sun isn't always shining
sometimes the wind blows at night you
want the electricity during the day so
we're putting in all sorts of storage
technologies like batteries flywheels
capacitors and hydrogen we're most
bullish on hydrogen as a storage
technology to store these energies so
that you can use them when you need them
because if the sun's under the clouds
you're in trouble you got to store it
when the sun's out and now we're taking
the electricity grid of Europe the whole
transmission grid and we're transforming
it to an energy internet using the same
technology we use with the communication
internet you know today everywhere in
the world that transmission electricity
grid is servo mechanical it's 60 years
old
it doesn't even digitalized it's
designed to be centralized and go in one
direction where the power is generated
nuclear fossil fuel power then you sent
it to the passive consumer at the end of
the line so this old transmission grid
wasn't designed to handle millions of
small players
generating green electricity on-site
solar wind etc and sending it back and
then controlling the peak and base loads
so we are actually transforming the
entire electricity grid of Europe to an
energy internet so when millions of
buildings are producing just tiny
amounts of green electricity storing it
in hydrogen like we stored media and
digital then if you don't need some of
that green electricity in your home
office or factory in a given moment you
can actually send your green electricity
across that energy internet from the
Irish Sea all the way to the edge of
Eastern Europe just like we create
information stored in digital shared
online that actual energy internet is
now coming online in real time it's
already out there in places like Denmark
and Germany in other places so the
energy internet is really the internet
brought to energy and it's a perfect fit
the great economic revolutions in
history occur when new energy regimes
emerge and new communication revolutions
emerge to organize them the 19th century
as we said yet to have steam power
printing to come together with coal and
steam power in the locomotive in the
20th century we had to have centralized
electricity and the telephone to manage
the complexities of an oil auto and
suburban era so here in the 21st century
the distributed collaborative
peer-to-peer internet communication and
that's its signature is now converging
with energies that are distributed have
to be organized collaboratively and
scale peer-to-peer renewable energies
are distributed they're found everywhere
but they're small amounts so you have to
create critical mass by collaborating
across entire continents to organize
that energy and then you share them in
lateral economies of scale so this is
the energy internet that's going along
with a communication internet to form
the beginning of this neural network and
this is already happening in real time
you